what's so special about the area of an
equilateral triangle to get to its area
we need to understand a few concepts
first all sides of the equilateral
triangle are equal to each other and so
are the angles all sides equal and all
angles equal so if we assume each angle
to be x degrees then three X would equal
180 degrees as the sum of angles of a
triangle is always 180 degrees each
angle will measure 60 degrees but again
the question is how do we get to the
area look at this equilateral triangle
with sides s if we drop a perpendicular
from a vertex onto its opposite side it
will divide it into two equal parts this
length will be s pi/2 and this length as
well will be s pi/2 this concept holds
true even for an isosceles triangle here
if we drop a perpendicular to this side
then these two lengths will be equal
both will equal Y by two so in a
triangle when we have two equal sides
and we drop a perpendicular from the
vertex joining the two equal sides to
its opposite side then that opposite
side is divided into two equal parts now
we can move on to the area of an
equilateral triangle look at this
equilateral triangle with sides s the
perpendicular divides the side into two
equal parts let this height be H now
look at the figure closely we need to
find the area of this equilateral
triangle only in terms of its side it
means we need to find its area in terms
of s how can we do that
think about it we know that the area can
be written as one half base times its
height the base is already in terms of s
now if we manage to get the height H in
terms of s our life will become
not easier now how can we get a CH in
terms of s look at this right triangle
for instance can be used the Pythagoras
theorem to get H in terms of s let's see
we can say that s squared is equal to H
squared plus s by 2 squared the square
of the hypotenuse is equal to the sum of
the squares of the other two sides
solving this we get H as root 3 by 2
times s now we have H in terms of s the
basic formula for the area of a triangle
is one half base times the height that
will be half the base is s and the
height is root three by two times s
solving this further we get the area of
an equilateral triangle as root three by
four times s squared that's our formula
to find the area of an equilateral
triangle all we need is the length of
one of its sides we can substitute it
here and get the area of course you are
not expected to know this derivation but
just in case you forget the area you
will know how to derive it quickly also
remember that when these two sides are
equal a perpendicular drop to the third
side divides it into two equal parts